When Bird Box flew onto Netflix in late December,
the post-apocalyptic horror thriller quickly
became something of a phenomenon.
All anyone on the Internet could talk, tweet,
and theorize about was Sandra Bullock's character
Malorie, her fight for survival in a world
where deadly entities spark global psychosis,
and how the planet tumbled into such terrifying
chaos.
But the two biggest mysteries that are still
lingering in viewers' minds are what the creatures
look like and why the movie didn't actually
show them.
Thanks to Bird Box screenwriter Eric Heisserer,
lead actress Bullock, and director Susanne
Bier, we now have answers to both those questions.
Heisserer, Bullock, and Bier recently sat
down for an interview with Bloody Disgusting,
and during the conversation, Heisserer revealed
that the film very nearly included a scene
in which the monsters are shown in their full
form.
Heisserer explained:
"There was a time when one of the producers
was like, 'No, you have to see something at
some point' and forced me to write essentially
a nightmare sequence where Malorie experiences
one in that house."
Bullock offered a detailed account of what
the monster looked like in the scene that
didn't make it into the final cut of Bird
Box:
"It was a green man with a horrific baby face.
It was snake-like, and I was like, 'I don't
want to see it when it first happens.
Just bring it into the room.
We'll shoot the scene.'
I turn and he's like this [growling at me].
It's making me laugh.
It was just a long fat baby."
After Bullock described the Bird Box monster,
director Bier chimed into the chat to explain
that the creature's design was a little more
terrifying in theory than they were in practice,
and that unveiling to viewers the monsters'
appearance would take away their power.
"It so easily becomes funny.
We actually shot that [scene] and spent a
lot of energy on [it], but every time I saw
it, I was like, 'This is not going to be tense.
It's just going to be funny."
Heisserer added that he was "so sorry" Bier
and Bullock had to shoot that sequence, but
with hindsight, everyone can laugh about the
situation and agree that the choice not to
show the monsters in Bird Box was the right
one.
Bier went on to explain that the more the
team looked at the monsters, the more powerless
they became.
"Whatever those beings are, they tap into
your deepest fear.
Everybody's deepest fear is going to be different
from the other person.
I think to suddenly take upon a concrete shape
in order to illustrate that becomes weak.
Where the conceit is really strong, then trying
to illustrate it is kind of almost meaningless.
So it would have been the wrong decision."
Opting to keep the monsters' appearance ambiguous,
only showing black shadows and wind gusts
to signal their impending arrival, was a smart
one, as it's often what we don't see that
scares us most.
However, as anyone who has seen Bird Box will
know, the film took the complete opposite
approach with its depiction of the violence
that the creatures cause, showing the self-killings
in great detail.
Bier explained the thought process behind
the all-in directorial choice, noting that
Netflix doesn't "have any inhibitions at all"
when it comes to such shocking sights and
that the Bird Box team wanted everything to
feel as real as possible without becoming
unnecessarily gory.
"I think we pretty much wanted to do it so
it felt real and at the time was harrowing.
But not so that would become the essence of
it.
It's pretty much done so it's kind of this
is what it would look like if they actually
did what they are doing.
I think if you stick to that, you get it relatively
realistic."
Bird Box remains the talk of Twitter and the
movie on everyone's mind, and with countless
viewers comparing the film to John Krasinski's
breakthrough fright-fest A Quiet Place, it's
certainly aiding the renaissance of sense
horror.
That the film has captivated so many people
without ever showing its main monsters is
perhaps an even bigger accomplishment.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.